l'actualité en france à présent avec
l'appel des magistrats français à une
journée de mobilisation nationale ce
sera le 15 décembre prochain oui dans le
prolongement de la tribune des 3000
magistrats et greffiers et avocats ont
décidé de s'unir pour dénoncer leurs
conditions de travail une tribune
soutenu par des premiers présidents et
des procureurs généraux c'est un fait
inédit qui en dit long sur une
institution j'ai dit judiciaire à bout
de souffle on va en parler justement
avec notre invité isabelle baigner ou
ben greffière secrétaire général du
syndicat des greffiers en france
[Musique]
bonjour isabelle baigner ou bains où ben
je ne sais pas j'espère que j'ai encore
ce pas votre nom il y à une mobilisation
un appel à une mobilisation pour le 15
décembre prochain suite à la tribune des
3000 magistrat qui avait été publiée
dans le monde c'est un ras-le-bol
c'est un ras-le-bol qui quitteraient
très ancrée auprès des fonctionnaires
magistrats également des d'avocats qui
nous ont rejoints pour cette
mobilisation du 15 décembre hélas pour
quelle raison précisément
pour quelle raison parce que la justice
est malade depuis très longtemps nous
avons actionné différents leviers auprès
des gardes des sceaux directeur des
services judiciaires depuis très très
longtemps pour les avertir leur disant
que on n'en peut plus magistrats
fonctionnaires on travaille dans des
conditions qui ne sont inhumaines pour
sur terre pour certains un seul exemple
ça fait trois semaines côté j'y glisse
ya plus de chauffage voilà est ce que
dans le prions d'accepter de travailler
son chauffage et là on est à bout tout
simplement qu'ils avaient des états
généraux de la justice qui ont été
lancées à la mi octobre par emmanuel
macron pourquoi ne pas profiter de ce
temps là pour faire vos doléances vous
n'y croyez pas
alors on n'y croit pas trop parce que
les questionnaires quand même
extrêmement formaté nos organisations
syndicales pour la plupart on n'est même
pas reçu par les groupes de travail ont
fait nos contributions par écrit et on
en fera enfin il entra fisc il en voudra
donc non on n'y croit pas trop où on a
déjà fait la justice du 21e siècle on a
eu des chantiers de la justice on a fait
six fois le l'état des lieux de ce qui
ne va pas sans pour autant avoir un sale
moment n'a pas entendu ce qui n'allait
pas dire que ce sont les moyens humains
et matériels qui ne vont pas depuis des
années des années on peut faire tous les
états généraux qu'on veut qu'il dans le
lot dès le départ on n'est pas ça est-ce
que vous avez l'oreille aux mordus du
ministre avec du pur moretti
alors il nous a reçus la semaine
dernière parce qu'ils sont bien quand
même que le mouvement de grogne commence
à se poindre mais après je ne sais pas
si cela durera ce qu eric dupond moretti
avait fait voter sa loi il s'était
félicité une nouvelle hausse du budget
de 8 % ça vous convainc pas là encore
cette hausse de budget de 8% alors qu'on
va pas quand on part de rien depuis des
années qu'elle peut paraître semanal
mais on est ce n'était rien depuis des
années et dans les 8 % nous honorerons
3,1 pour cent pour les savait judiciaire
et le reste pour l'administration
pénitentiaire à la pige il ya un autre
problème que vous soulevez c'est le
recours le recours aux intermittents si
je puis dire dans la justice aux sucres
rapides comme ils appellent ça
effectivement ce sont des gens qui sont
lents été recruté avec plus ou moins des
niveaux scolaires en fonction des postes
proposés à qui on a fait une semaine de
formation
dans le même temps ce sont des gens avec
une semaine de formation que l'on met en
poste dans des juridictions qui vont
faire le même travail que nous grassi
qui sont formés pendant 18 mois belle
des autorisations la profession de la
part de monsieur dupont moretti qui
était avocat il ya un pic dans les
greffes et qui sait ce que c'est que des
graphies sans qu'on me donne ça ne va
pas du tout qu'est ce que vous réclamez
concrètement les moyens le mcs des
moyens humains et matériels c'était très
noir et rose c'est à dire une vraie un
vrai plan de deux ans bausch sur
plusieurs années et à dire des concours
que l'on fait avec des vrais
fonctionnaires comme particularité alors
yahia c'est un fait inédit les premiers
présidents et les procureurs généraux
soutiennent cette fois le mouvement
ça en dit long
bâton bilan parce que c'est quand même
une première dans l'institution
judiciaire de les voir avec nous dans la
même galère entre nous mais il faut que
ça n'y auront plus dans le temps alors
il ya une mobilisation nationale le 15
décembre prochain comment ça va se
passer est ce que c'est il y aura une
grande manifestation à paris
alors il est prévu par un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales et
manifestations à paris et après il est
prévu des mouvements locaux des
rassemblements sur l'heure de midi un
film en se donnant chaque palais chaque
pas les bateaux organisé comme ils
veulent souhaiter il ya aussi la
question de de la réforme des retraites
on s'en souvient les avocats étaient
vent debout contre contre cette réforme
ça aussi ça fera partie des
revendications alors s'en fait pas par
client là on est vraiment sûr sur
l'institution son fonctionnement et sa
paupérisation depuis des années est ce
que vous comptez sur sur une réforme de
fond est ce que vous espérez encore des
réponses du gouvernement actuel on
espère et dans notre fait dans notre
logique on espère toujours un ont fait
bien que toute façon ça ne se fera pas
du jour au lendemain parce que si on
veut des recrutements il faut du temps
mais d avoir acté sur le papier qu'ils
auront lieu et qu'on arrêtera de mettre
des sucres rapides pour mettre des gens
qui seront en place pour longtemps et
pas en fonction d'un gouvernement ou
d'une envie et ça c'est un problème qui
était qui étaient présents bien sûr
avant la crise du code vide alors avant
la clé ducobu de toute façon oui
effectivement on avait des taux de
vacance qui était déjà important tant
chez les magistrats que chez les
fonctionnaires et qui ne font que se
creuser la pelouse du coc vide a fait
que des gens aujourd'hui bas il
n'accepte plus à peine conditions qui
étaient les leurs par le passé aussi
merci beaucoup et isabelle baigner ou
band avoir répondu ce matin en direct à
nos questions sur rt france oui merci en
bas